i worked on the cover for about for just
less than 14 years so i used to catch
drug dealers for a living essentially
and over that space of time
i realized that
everything that i was doing was not only
futile because futility would be bad
enough but it actually was causing
immense harm not only to individuals who
were vulnerable people who needed help
but also it was actively increasing the
levels of crime particularly violent
crime
in our society
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our fantastic guest today is a
former undercover police officer here in
the uk neil woods welcome to
trigonometry thank you it's great to
have you on the show we've got so much
to talk with you about we're going to
talk about drugs we're going to talk
about corruption and the police force
we'll talk about lots of things before
we do for those people in our audience
watching and listening who don't know
who you are what is your story who are
you how are you where you are how are
you sitting here talking to us
uh well i am a former police officer
former undercover police officer uh and
i worked undercover for about for just
less than 14 years
um
and i used to
almost entirely investigate uh drugs
offences so i used to catch drug dealers
for a living essentially
and over that space of time
i realized that
everything that i was doing was not only
futile because futility would be bad
enough but it actually was causing
immense harm not only to individuals who
were vulnerable people who needed help
but also it was actively increasing the
levels of crime in particular violent
crime
in our society
and
like
many police officers like me around the
world uh we i now campaign as part of an
international movement
for an evidence-based drug policy to
take the power away from organized crime
um
go for it well all i was going to say is
before we get into talking about policy
and all of that just talk to us through
the process of what you actually used to
do
yeah i used to
travel
from one inner city area to another
and i would work undercover in those
areas for around six or seven months
and
i would essentially
pretend to be a problematic drug
consumer i would network amongst people
like that
people who lived in squats and homeless
and street people
and i would get them to introduce me
up the chain
to the local drug dealers and then
buy increasingly large amounts network
with the sort of regional controllers to
see how far up the ladder i could get
and infiltrate those gangs to gather
evidence of conspiracy
and then they would all get arrested
the the culmination of that operation um
[Music]
so surely if i'm a normal person listen
to this i'm going well you've done a
smashing job you've come along you've
outed a great drug gang they all get
arrested they'll get locked up isn't
that brilliant for protecting the
community from the evil of drugs
well you i i used to believe so i used
to think you know this is this is great
i'm so privileged to be uh part of the
police who go after the most dangerous
people in our society
but the reality is that
whilst the police are very very good at
catching drug dealers and they are
really good at it
if you gave them twice the resources and
told them to catch twice as many than
they would
but that's part of the problem
that's actually a significant part of
the problem because the police never
reduce the size of the market
but they do change the shape of it
and if you regress it if you police it
more aggressively
then you change it more aggressively
and what it means is that perpetually
gets more violent because you create a
darwinian situation on the streets of
our nation and around the world
where the most ruthless and violent
criminals are the ones that are left
behind and successful
drugs policing
sharpens the sword of organized crime
and nothing sharpens it as much as
covert policing like the kind of thing
that i used to do but it took me a long
time to realize that you know i had to i
had to
face up to
the evidence before my eyes uh
and it's odd you know when you're really
wrapped up in that world of covert
policing the intensity of it
you are resistant to that evidence you
know you you're so wrapped up you you've
got to have that drive and believe in
what you're doing
um
and and to be honest and look around and
be honest about the impact of it that
that took time for me i was a bit slow
was there a single moment that sparked
an epiphany in you where you thought
hang on a second
i'm doing more harm than good here
there's there was a lot to be honest
because i was resistant to it and
there's probably three key ones do you
want me to run through them but those
briefly okay so
i suppose the first one was uh
or one of the first was in
nottinghamshire and
i i just sort of worked out that
i really needed to network amongst
the homeless people the people who are
really struggling with life so i i was
learning to dress down and
be really filthy clothes disgusting
clothes
and i even developed a technique that at
the end of the day i would time take my
clothes off and tie them up in a plastic
bag and put them in a warm place
overnight so they'd really smell the
next day
which my backup team used to love as you
can imagine
in fact they loved it so much they would
they would that were driving me to to
this
to the plot uh the place where i was
working with the day um to drop me off
and they were driving me with the
windows blown down and their heads out
the window shouting you dirty bastard
which you know was nice but um i could
see the point i was i was a mess i
looked to my smelter mass anyway
they dropped me off and i started
walking to meet this heroin dealer that
i've been buying weights of heroin off
for for quite a while
and as i'm walking along it's it's where
the red light area used to be in
nottingham
um near where the goose fare isn't
and it's a long
bendy road
and as i'm walking on this road i hear
this this voice that said sex for sale
and i thought i know this is nottingham
but half past one in the afternoon
that's quite forward
and i kept walking and again i heard sex
for sale
i didn't see her that i had heard again
sex for sale and then as the road
straightened up i saw her as i'm walking
towards her
she looked me up and down obviously this
day to me she looked me up and down and
said
cheap sex for sale
well
i walked past i didn't think anything
more of it
and
i went to buy the heroine from the
dealer
[Music]
and then i did an evidence drop and then
i went to buy some crack cocaine and
then at the end of the day i did a
debrief because what you do you sit
around with the team you you evidence
the you know you go through the evidence
uh
system you tell them and tell everyone
tell the whole team needs to know what's
going on in other words
and i told them about this woman
offering me cheap sex and they all
laughed
and whenever i've had a big audience in
front of me or a group of people they've
always laughed and i trained later
undercover cops later and everyone
laughs
but when i look back on that day
if i can close my eyes and i've got no
idea what the heroin deal looks like
it's just one more dealer in an endless
endless stream of dealers but i can
picture her completely she was tall slim
and she wasn't the day over 21 and she
was clutching a kind of special brew
and she was clutching that special brew
because she was trying to fend off for
withdrawal from heroin
which is what took her that withdrawal
is what took her to the streets of
nottingham to offer me
cheap sex
and
it sort of haunted me that night because
i represented all of the resources of
the state
and was a lot of resources into me all
my backup team and
and i walked right past her
there was no other resources there
to help her and she clearly needed help
and that sort of suppose it was one of
the first clues to me that something
really wasn't right here
because there's always another dealer
and theoretically
the way that cops talked at the time
theoretically what i was doing was to
protect her
was to stop these evil drugs getting
onto the streets and corrupting people
like her that's the theory isn't it
and yet
she was there on the streets
because she's got no no legal protection
so that was one thing
and another thing was um
what i learned was
that
in order to
get get people to do what i want i have
to manipulate them and so i would always
seek out the most vulnerable people
because they're the easiest to
manipulate
and if that seems ruthless
well of course it's ruthless
that is the nature of undercover drugs
policing it's bloody ruthless
um
and so one guy i i
manipulated in nottingham guy called
cami um i mean i got really friendly
with him i wooed him you know
and i weird him because he was very
useful to me because he was on the
periphery
the very periphery of an organization
called the best wood cartel he was a
user dealer for them
and um
how did you woo him
well i spent time with him but most
importantly i used empathy
i listened to him
and
you know i heard about his problematic
childhood abusive father that kind of
thing and i just spent time listening
but also i had some fun with him i went
shoplifting with him
which is
which was great fun no no seriously well
you know if you know you've got to get
out for a jake jail card it's great
especially if you're acting a pair you
know take turns and being look out that
kind of thing
anyway um
so i spent a lot of time with him
and you know that was another very
successful operation i think there was
56 people arrested
a few decent gangsters uh but the thing
with the trouble is he was arrested as
well and he was committing offences on
bail that i was gathering evidence
against him for while i was being
friendly with him
and when he was in police custody
he ended up being on minute to minute
watch
suicide watch
and as he told the interviewing officers
the reason for that is that this was the
last straw for him it was the last
it was the biggest blow for him because
he thought he'd finally found a friend
he could talk to he'd never had that
before
and that's what made him suicidal
so therein lies the ruthlessness really
um
and don't you know that hit me like a
ton of bricks and that it was just
emotionally disturbing to me
and then
i suppose that the real
defining mode but i still went into it
though i still carried on because i was
persuaded to do it
because
it was pitched to me that look these
next gangsters they're even worse than
the last lot
we need you to catch them and by this
time i'd become a sort of
i suppose a troubleshooter so that
because i'd had some success i got the
reputation and that meant that i got the
more difficult jobs
and
the job
the next job i did the burger bar boys
that had two other other undercover cops
tried to get close to them and they
hadn't managed it so they persuaded me
to to have a go and that's why i went
back into the work
but for that operation
i mean i almost got i was convinced i
was going to die on several several
times in that operation i was stripped
at gunpoint
i was assaulted
um
it was a every single day of the
operation in the company of the burger
bar boys when i was with them
i i always felt that there was a
potential imminent violence every single
day
but at the end of the seven months
i've got evidence against 96 people the
six main gangsters and 90 other people
all the sex workers that they were
employing runners or all these people
and i knew there was actually no one
else to catch because there were no new
phone numbers that i hadn't already got
no people mentioned that i hadn't
already met
so i thought wow this is just going to
wipe the place clean this is
extraordinary
and there were cops brought in hundreds
of cops brought in five different
counties provided help for this
and so
i thought this is going to be a dramatic
effect anyway two weeks afterwards or
sometime
after the event
the intel officer spoke to me who was
tasked with keeping his air to the
ground just to see the impact of the
operation
and he said to me yep we managed to
interrupt the heroin and drug heroin and
crack cocaine supply in northampton for
a full two hours
seven months of work 96 people arrested
all of that
trauma that still scars me to this day
from that event from that operation to
interrupt it for just two hours
that's not even enough time for someone
to rattle from heroin
hey francis have you decided what to get
your dad for father's day same thing as
always a couple of pints down the dog
and duck class a new brexit means brexit
car sticker to replace the one i got him
last year mate brexit was in 2016 do you
not think he might want something a bit
more up to date like a new ridge wallet
this is mine it's smooth sleek stylish
and it can hold 12 cards and there's
also a clip on the back for cash as well
it's not going to create a bulge in your
trousers like those bulky old wallets
it'll make your dad look like a top
level player
great idea he can also put his brexit
sticker on it which means a problematic
older ladies are gonna love him
yeah okay the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
just one wallet for the rest of your
life rich are so confident in their
product they'll give you 45 days to test
drive their wallet that means you can
get the wallet use it and if you don't
like it you can return it in 45 days
unlike brexit
because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 15 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns
that's 15
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special promo
code which is of course trigger
you know
it shouldn't have shocked me because
i've been observing this kind of thing
[Music]
for years these doubts have been
creeping in but that was a very stark
piece of reality that two hours before
the new phone number and someone been
able to deliver just like that now i
don't know
for certain that the burger bar boys
infamous rivals the johnson crew
were the people who took up that
opportunity that we'd created for them
but you can sort of picture the scene
can't you the rival gang they're all sat
around maybe having a smoke one of them
comes in says wow boys put the call in
we're gonna make a fortune guess what
the cops have done for us they've locked
up the burger bar boys
wow and they'll be celebrated and that's
the reality
that wherever and this is every level
at every level from the streets of the
uk
to to transnational organized crime
does if you if you if you catch someone
you're always making someone else happy
because the market never shrinks
and
the the really grim irony actually
for the burger bar boys arrest if it was
the johnson crew who took up that
opportunity and bought a load more drugs
and sold them you know for the next few
weeks and months
all the drugs that were caught that were
found with the burger bar boys
the guy that supplied them the next rung
of the ladder
get to supply them twice because he
supplies the opposition as well
so he's he's really happy because he
sold the same markets drugs twice
this is the reality people need to
understand
so
and that is such
i mean it's depressing really because
what it's showing people and what it's
demonstrating is that you're never going
to get rid of demand there's always
going to be a demand for these type of
hard drugs so that being the case
what should we do now
well we have to take control because
it's out of control at the moment we
have to take control by legally
regulating the market you know the these
worst elements in our society are only
are only empowered because we've given
this given them this tremendous power
there's this huge financial benefit of
the illegal drugs trade
we've created this problem through drug
prohibition we created this problem by
burning the drugs so we have to take
control
we have to regulate the product now
people you know people get scared of
that idea
because it's normally presented as we
need to legalize and this one word is a
scary word isn't it it conjures all
sorts of
images like uncertainty and maybe a
free-for-all
but
you need to break it down into actual
policy chunks about what that means
individual policies
because it's not a free-for-all the
free-for-all is now
it's the wild west now this is about
taking control back so for example
heroin
that's the easiest one to regulate we
wouldn't even need a change in the law
we just go back to the british system
and the british system is um
it's the way we used to do it in the uk
that if someone had a problem with drugs
if they found themselves addicted to
heroin or cocaine they would go to the
doctor and they'd get help
rational pragmatic help
and what that would mean is that they
would get a prescription from the doctor
just a pragmatic medical response to an
unfortunate medical condition
and we had the british system since the
1920s right up until the end of the
1960s it was it was stopped by the
diplomatic pressure of the united states
but at the end of the british system in
the 1960s
there was only 1046
heroin consumers in the uk and the
number was falling
within 20 years of the british system
ending
we had 300 000
and there's a very clear cause and
effect there
that the market was given to organize
crime suddenly there was a big financial
incentive for people to make a huge
amount of money from it and organized
crime have long been good at
exploiting people particularly
where there is poverty and inequality
but also
where people are traumatized because
and i i found this out
actually by
using my empathy and listening to people
over the years that i worked undercover
i refer to it now as weaponizing empathy
um
but but i did learn a lot
and i learned
that
almost all
of the people who are using heroin and
crack cocaine
almost all of these people are
self-medicating for
trauma and most of it is childhood
trauma
sexual abuse physical abuse
and
neglect and
but of course now
now that i'm an activist
now i read
the academic papers on these topics and
the academic papers also back that up
that at least two-thirds of problematic
heroin and crack cocaine consumers are
self-medicating for these things
and organized crime exploit these people
[Music]
and
until we banned
those drugs organized crime couldn't
exploit those people
so we lead them to the mercy of
organized crime rather than taking care
of them as a society which is
just it's just disgusting really when
you when you think about it
it's an argument that makes a lot of
sense when we sit down and have this
conversation in this way
and i know that you deal with
politicians and you know you you
interact with people who who have the
power to change this what do they say to
you to to these arguments
well i mean it depends who it is um and
it's important to to
observe i think when talking about
politicians in their views that
politicians
to what they perceive the public believe
you know as tony benn famously said
politicians are either signposts or
weather vanes
which is a rather cynical way of saying
that
because i have no problem with
politicians being politicians you know i
have no problem with them uh
behaving the way that they want their
constituents to behave it's just that's
just politics
but they're a little out of touch
at the moment the public are ahead of
them
but sorry to answer your question uh
many of them will just
well most of them don't understand the
issue that's the most important thing to
say they don't understand the issue or
even some conservative politicians
but they just they just they just don't
i mean you know the the
the daftest statements come out of so
many politicians right across the
political spectrum
they will say that drugs cause these
harms
and what they're saying they're
evidencing that drug prohibition causes
these harms and it's a
it doesn't take much explanation to get
it no well you just did it in 10 minutes
yeah exactly but we have to have that
opportunity to be able to talk to them
which is why
i'm always very grateful
for interviews and conversations like
this because i can say to an audience if
you contact your mp they will listen to
you if you email your mp they will
listen to you they all tell me that
that they sit up and take notice if they
if they have
an email three times on the same topic
they're sitting up and taking notice of
it
but
but there are you know there's a there's
a variety of views but i have to say
that the growing support amongst
politicians for drug law reform is a is
across the political spectrum it doesn't
sit any particular place it's not of the
left and it's not of the right
it's scattered across the whole
political spectrum which is encouraging
and it's good and it's the way it should
be neil that is good but the question i
asked you was really trying to get out
why hasn't it happened yet
if you're right and if what you're
saying is correct and i'm sure it is
why have we not had drug policy reform
yet
right
i love that question because
there's an aspect of this that i'm
working on very hard at the moment now
there's a there's a few answers to that
one is that the press and the media have
misrepresented drugs and drug policy and
the results of it
for decades journalists media gurus
can talk whatever [ __ ] they want about
drugs because they know they can get
away with it they don't have to evidence
it and they do make up a load of [ __ ]
about it
that's one reason
politicians
spouting moralistic rubbish is another
problem but the biggest problem and i've
come to believe this the biggest problem
is what the police say
now this is not the fault of the police
i have to have to stress because the the
police have a duty to inform the public
of what they do
they also have a duty to maintain public
confidence
so
when the police
do a series of arrests
or they seize a load of drugs
then they present this to the public in
the news or on social media as a success
and they do this increasingly actually
on social they're getting more
sophisticated at doing this on social
media so the police are constantly
bombarding the images to the public of
big sieges of cocaine
big cannabis factories
all the time
and
this is like
powerful marketing
these are the same images repeated over
and over it's either the drug seizures
or it's the rows of mug shots of a gang
that's been caught they're constantly
repeated to the public and the message
that the public gets is that
well for one they're reminded there's
something to be scared of
and second they're reassured that the
police are doing something look at that
what they've done look all the drugs
they've caught
and they're reassured so the public are
told it's essentially that the current
policy works
but it's dishonest
it's not true and the police know this
from their own criminal databases they
create their own criminal intelligence
that actually more often than not
drugs policing increases crime in an
area because if you create a gap in the
market
then two or more people will fight over
that gap and violence goes up happens
time and time again police know this but
they're not telling the public that are
they they're not telling the public that
this will not prevent anybody from
getting hold of their drugs it's not
even going to put the price up until
it's making no difference at all
but it's not the way it's presented to
the public now you have to see this in
comparison with with conventional crime
because if police arrest the burglar
burglaries will go down
because there are a limited number of
people who will commit a burglary so
that is a positive
provable
activity
drugs policing
does not reduce crime
but the police are constantly telling
the public that it is
so that i think
is the biggest impediment
to the growth of the social movement
because
like any social justice issue in history
change with drug policy will come
through the growth of the social
movement rather than political
leadership
same as any social movement whether it's
gender equality
the illegality of homosexuality whatever
it is comes from social movement
and what the police are constantly daily
telling the public is slowing down that
movement which is why
is one of the reasons why leap
my organization is so important because
it falls on us really we are duty-bound
to challenge those narratives
and when we were talking with carl hart
about this he made such a good point
which is
we've been in
the the messages and the narratives that
we've been given
from mainstream media from movies from
books they're so infantile you know the
junky
and
the moment i say that word we can all
picture that particular person
in our heads but it's a two-dimensional
character and like you said it doesn't
address the fact that this is obviously
someone deeply traumatized deeply
damaged using drugs to just be able to
cope and function throughout life not
really function either just exist
yeah exactly and it's dehumanizing isn't
it yeah it's always dehumanizing uh
language and you different regions
around the uk have their favorites you
know
uh
bagrat is one of my most detested ones
but you know
i say it just so that people can be
aware of just how dehumanizing it can be
and carl's right i mean i love carl
his angle on this is
on that topic is
is very good
um
[Music]
i've lost my thread no it's so it's fine
we were talking about how mainstream
media
films dehumanize people who take drugs
and what they do is essentially
infantilize a very complex disgusting
conversation yeah exactly and i i mean
there's so many examples i could give
you but one that sticks in my head is
there's a there was a young woman called
uma who i spoke to i got to know quite
well
and she she was amazing
she was one of the most generous people
i've ever met um
and this is very common amongst
problematic heroin users actually
they're really really generous and i i
because i'd had some people being
suspicious of me having money i decided
to play rattling one day just pretend to
be rattling with drawing
and so i wandered around in the morning
you know
obviously rattling and holding my that's
the way i was holding myself and uma
came over to me and says hey mate you
hanging out
i said yeah yeah
but i'll be all right when i get some
money and she just
pulled a fiver out of her pocket it says
there you go mate
this is well aren't you going to need
that she's not i'm fine i'll just add
some i'll be all right for the next few
hours you need it now
just
absolute pure unadult unadulterated
honesty she saw the need she didn't give
it a second thought she was incredible
but she said to me one day
she said well i can stop using i do
actually every few weeks i stopped to
bring my tolerance down to stop for a
couple of weeks
just but the problem is when i stop i
become suicidal
because i remember
the feeling of my uncle's fingernails
when he used to sexually assault me as a
little girl
so for her
unlike so many like her
taking heroine was a pragmatic
rational decision very rational kept her
alive
it helped to forget
heroin's actually really
really good at helping people deal with
trauma
really good
that's why they do it that's why people
do it
to cope with trauma not deal with i
would say to cope with trauma right
yeah that's a good correction actually
to to cope with to to to blot it out in
the absence of any other care well we're
exactly this is what i was going to go i
mean it strikes me that obviously one of
the problems here is we've got people
who are not getting mental health and
ways of processing trauma which are
available i mean they're there we know
how to help people who've been through a
trauma now we've got tools to do it
but they're obviously falling through
the cracks and then that's when
you find ways to cope instead of
addressing the issue right ravines
rather than cracks yeah yeah exactly man
it's it's it's an awful thing to think
about really and obviously for you to
have seen that
uh to see so many people go through that
it
i don't know like where do we go from
here neil
where do we go yeah where do we go well
i don't know what to ask you because
what you're what you're saying makes
absolute 100
logical sense to me and every guest we
had on particularly in recent times i've
become more bad cop when we interview
people and i'm like
testing their ideas and trying to find
a floor in their argument and
it's a no-brainer to me yeah absolutely
i mean the evidence is so powerful
the arguments are so clear this is so
clearly
just
rational and logic
that it makes our job as anyone involved
in the drug law reform world it makes
our job very easy to to explain people
but we just need the platforms which is
why i'm so really grateful for you to
invite me to come and speak to you
because it's the platforms we need we
need people out there sharing it we need
people out there discussing it with
their friends and family and getting
them to watch this
this is how we win
we this is this is the process of the
social movement growing so i really
appreciate it
but where to go from here in terms of
policy well i mean you know we could
have over overdose prevention sites like
they have in european countries in
canada no one's died in one of those
anywhere since they started anywhere in
the world and yet our government is
saying no there's no excuse for that
we've got the biggest drug deaths in
europe scotland's biggest drug deaths in
the world per capita we need overdose
prevention sites right now
just it needs to be urgently happening
we need to be contacting every one of
our mps to demand it we need heroin
assisted treatment which is the british
system revived
it's happening already in cleveland
paid for by the money from the police
and crime commissioner actually the
police are paying for this which is you
know the police being ahead of the
politics in this country is
extraordinary really
we need a legally regulated cannabis
market
to protect our children because it's
easier for our children to get cannabis
than it is alcohol
because dealers don't ask for id
do they
and you know there is evidence from
north america that regulated markets
protect our children better so we need
to protect them but also you
regulate the cannabis markets and you're
taking a huge amount of money out of the
pockets of organized crime
which they always reinvest profits into
corruption
so we're making our society safer and
more secure this is a security issue
we're making our society more secure if
we do that we take that money away from
them and also from a public health
perspective
we don't know what's in that bag of
green
that our dealer delivers not really
you know some connoisseurs might
have something to say about what i've
just said but more often than not we
don't so
and every commodity needs to be
it needs to be regulated to protect
people and you know and all the drugs in
between they need to be sold by licensed
pharmacies now if you consider mdma for
example
mgma is the perfect example of the drug
that
is not banned because it's dangerous
it's dangerous because it's banned
and i'm sure but you had dave not on i
would imagine he's he's commenting on on
this as well you know this is all of the
deaths that come from mdma is because
it's unregulated is because it's not
what people expected
or it's a tablet which is four or five
times too too big a dose
these are regulatory issues
regulate that drug and you literally
save lives
mdma deaths will be virtually
non-existent
and also
who are we to judge who is anyone to
judge if someone wants to drop an mdma
pill
and dance to electronic music in a field
or wherever
who cares
it's just
there's
the sort of liberty arguments don't get
talked about very often but really
it's
we need to have parallels with
the social movement that ended the
illegality of homosexuality and it's
still developing to end the prejudice
because it's not for anyone to judge
what other people do with their own mind
and body is it
and we need to be talking in those terms
and that's
not a popular view within the drug law
reform world that because as it's
pointed out to me by some allies
you can't argue about personal liberty
because not enough people care about
personal liberty because they don't
you know we've seen that over coming
yeah exactly they just don't they don't
care yeah so but i still
even though
the evidence suggests that other
arguments are stronger i always like to
mention it because
it's another topic of conversation we
need to get out there
what right do we have to judge anybody
what they do with their own mind and
body what right does anyone have well i
suppose on that one there is a counter
argument i can think of which is drugs
have an impact on people beyond the
person who's taking them right um
so i can see the argument for that i
just think when it comes to that your
explanation of why people take drugs i
just think we you need a different
approach yes someone becoming a drug
addict it has an impact on their family
on people around them on society it's
not good but the way to deal with that
is to address the cause of what's making
them take the drugs i suppose what do
you think is the strongest argument
against your position
strongest argument against the thing you
find most difficult to have to to deal
with when people if people challenge you
uh
about decriminalization or legalization
i can't think of a single rational
strong argument to be honest i mean you
know all of the opponents
of drug law reform are just bat [ __ ]
crazy
they're just moral it's just moral
judgment how can you argue with moral
judgment i mean you said you've had
peter itchings on
he's just just looking at it from a
moralistic lens he wants to judge and
control people
he hasn't got any rational arguments at
all he argues that cannabis
is behind terrorism and violence and
it's not the evidence is quite clear it
isn't
um
so
there really isn't any argument that's
difficult to counter honestly but i i i
appreciate you challenging that point i
made then though
and it's an important point you just
made
and
it prompts me to make clear that
not all drug use is problematic
in fact 90 percent of drug use is not
problematic
and the 10 that is problematic it's a
sliding scale so some people need more
intervention than others the important
thing to note about our current drug
laws about the system of prohibition is
it makes problematic use
more likely and more dangerous
because people are pushed to the margins
they're criminalized so they're not able
to get help
so wherever you look around the world
where there is less prohibition and more
harm reduction
for that prop for that
problematic cohort
they there is less problematic
consumption so for example in portugal
where they've decriminalized possession
they haven't gone the whole way and
legalized
legally regulated the market yeah but
they've decriminalized possession so
people who have a problem with drugs
they get help
so their problematic consumption has
dramatically dropped their overall
consumption hasn't dropped
there's still just as many people taking
drugs as there was before it's made no
difference to that their problematic
consumption has gone down
their problems with blood-borne viruses
has gone down their drug deaths have
dropped they used to be the highest now
they're the lowest
you can't argue with that
no you can't
you alluded to something that the money
from drugs
then went into corruption
and the one thing that i wanted to talk
with you about well there's lots of
things obviously this has been an
incredible interview so thank you for
coming on but
it's corruption within the police
because it's something that i don't
think we talk about enough and i'll give
you an example we all know the stephen
lawrence case the racist murder of
stephen lawrence obviously awful
obviously horrendous and we all talk
about the racist element of it because
it played a large part but we don't also
talk about the fact
that the coppers involved a lot of them
were
corrupt how big is a is corruption
within the police force a problem and
how much of it is due
to these gangs being awash with drugs
and being able to buy
coppers and make them
corrupt it's huge
it's the scale of corruption that's
caused by drug prohibition is
eye-watering and uncomfortable now i i
make
lots of my former colleagues
uncomfortable by saying this because it
feels like it's a criticism of them it's
not it's still a tiny minority of cops
but a tiny marionity of cops can do a
massive massive load of harm
and it's absolutely endemic it's endemic
and
impossible to defend against
impossible
because there's too much money involved
there is more money in the criminality
of the illicit drug markets than
anything any other form of criminality
anything
but it's not just the money
which
causes the corruption it's the mechanism
of trying to police the drug markets
actually causes it
now bear with me i'll try to try and
explain this
so where the police have a successful
operation and they arrest say a drug
dealer which controls the heroin supply
in a quarter of the city
the dealer or kingpin character or gang
which is more able which is able to take
up that opportunity or most able to take
up that opportunity created by that
policing activity
is someone who controls another quarter
of the city
so they expand their influence they
increase their market share
which means they expand they increase
their disposable income
and the police are continually changing
the market like this continually
and what happens is you get people
increasing their market share or you get
people forming monopolies or you get
people forming cooperatives
which means there's more money able to
be invested in corruption
and over time this mechanism is what
increases corruption and this happens at
every level all over the world
one of the best examples for it is in
mexico yeah there used to be 20 cartels
now there's only three cartels each one
of those three cartels
has a gdp
if you put it in those terms bigger than
most west african countries
those west african countries have been
corrupted completely
in the last 12 months there have been
five military coups in west africa
each one of those military coups has
been about the control of the big single
biggest financial letter asset for those
nations
and the single biggest financial asset
is the money that's made through the
cocaine transit routes
it's about who controls the bribes from
transnational organized crime as what's
driven those military coups
so countries like guinea guinea-bissau
senegal
sierra leone these countries are now
narco states
they are not run by legitimate
democratic institutions they're run by
transnational organized crime because
why corrupt
a customs official and a police chief
when you can afford to take over the
whole government
and they can afford to take over the
whole government because of decades of
policing activity
which has thinned them out and made the
last one standing
incredibly rich
this is destroying
the fabric of our democracy and our
security worldwide
the global initiative into trans
transnational organized crime which is a
body which studies international
uh police criminal intelligence
they made a day center report they put a
republican report last september which
stated that
the growing power of transnational
organized crime now the single biggest
threat to our security and the even the
the system of democracy itself
and we're doing this
by fighting this war
by trying to deal with police by trying
to deal with drugs by policing and this
happens at every level now we feel very
smug in our stable democracy
in the uk very smug
but the corruption is here as well and
i've come across it
numerous times
i
once in a the operation in nottingham
uh we've been working very long hours
and two of my backup team went off sick
in the morning i got introduced to these
two new cops i'd not met before which
which unsettled me a little
shook the hand of the first one no
problem with him at all
shook the hand of the second one and the
hairs just went up in the back of my
neck
you know i'd been working undercover for
months by this time and my senses were
pretty fine-tuned verging on paranoia
and this guy was just wrong
he was clearly wrong to me instinctively
so i went to the guy running the
operation he said boss
sorry don't trust this guy don't want
him anywhere near it i don't want him
knowing what i'm doing
this is fine we'll exclude him exclude
them both so they don't ask any
questions and they don't know anything
about this job yet so it's fine
didn't think much more of it but then 12
months later when the gangster collin
gun was brought down
it turned out that that cop was an
employee of colin gunn he'd paid him to
join the police
his name was charlie fletcher
his
details are all over you know on the
internet he by the time i met him he'd
been in the police for seven years
[ __ ] hell and he was being paid to 2
000 pounds a month
on top of his police wages plus bonuses
for good information
now he'd been paid to join the police
in the debrief for that
one of us one senior cop said to me at
the time look what's he
yeah of course this happens we know this
happens
with this much money involved how can it
not happen
and it is accepted and understood by
senior covert police all over the
country that this happens
but why doesn't the public know this
don't you think the public should know
this
but the problem is that one of the
standing directives from the home office
to chief constables is to maintain
public confidence
makes sense doesn't it if the public
lose confidence in the police fabric of
society could break down and all that
but the trouble is that means that
constable chief constables are not being
honest with the public and if the public
knew
the extent
of the corruption
then i think the public would quite
quickly demand change of their mps
now consider the the mechanisms that i
used to work under as an undercover cop
before i got before i got loaned to a
particular constabulary they would have
to set up their operation as dictated by
the special operations unit
we'd have to have an intel guy an
exhibits guy
back up
and in a certain cell and they were not
when they were told they were not
allowed to even communicate with their
colleagues during the whole operation
they were completely separate people
wouldn't know where they'd gone or what
they were doing
they were told
just before i got there that they were
not allowed to ask me my real name not
allowed to ask me where i'm from and
they would be disciplined
punished if they did
so i was giving i was working with the
cops using the same pseudonym as i was
with the gangsters
and of course the reason for that is to
try and protect me
now consider this
that only happens for covert drugs
operations
doesn't have any other kind of policing
none at all oh no apart from witness
protection which is all about drugs
witnesses anyway all of it
so that system
in itself
is evidence
of just how seriously and the extent of
corruption that exists as a result of
our drug policy
hey francis do you go on the internet to
look at naughty stuff
yeah is it stuff that you'd be
embarrassed to show your friends
yeah is it stuff that would get you
cancelled yeah well next time you decide
to be naughty and watch more
trigonometry you need to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter mate because i use
incognito mode
it doesn't matter what mode you use or
how many times you clear your browsing
history your internet service provider
can still see every single website
you've ever visited that's why even when
you're at home you should never go
online without using expressvpn my
career is finished they're there you'll
have to leave trigonometry can't be
helped anyway it doesn't matter who your
internet service provider is isps in the
us can legally sell your information to
ad companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the site you visit absolutely
fastest
expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time
you won't even realize you have
expressvpn on it runs seamlessly in the
background and is so easy to use all you
have to do is tap one button and you're
protected what am i gonna do
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you not to
be using it go on francis do the last
bit
you don't want to end up like me protect
your online activity today
with a vpn rated number one my business
insider
visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com slash trigger and you can
get an extra three months free on a one
year package that's e x p r e s s v p n
dot com slash trigger
expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
and neil those corrupt cops they're
particularly dangerous aren't they
because i remember you saying on another
interview that actually
if
you know you aren't worried about former
gangsters
but former police officers that's
something else entirely oh god
absolutely yeah i mean
for drug wars we interviewed a good
friend of mine um frank matthews and he
had a big problem with corruption
in the mat
and there's a surprise
well it happens everywhere it happens
everywhere but his problems are
definitely all here well he worked here
and he was a whistleblower for corrupt
activity and when he was a whistleblower
he ended up being followed by an entire
um
entire surveillance unit of special
branch he was being surveilled by his
own team and he got to the point
with problems that he was having with he
cops that he knew were corrupt
was that
he thought he was going to get killed
and
he's he's one of the he's someone who's
had more dealings with gangsters than
probably anyone i know
some very high level and international
organized crime figures and they've
never worried him as much as the corrupt
cops and i have to say exactly the same
thing
it's the corruption
and negligence within policing that's
almost got me killed
more often than than not
and again you know i
i apologize to many of my colleagues
which really which really
get offended by this but we all need to
be honest we all need to be honest
because
the way to protect
our police our criminal justice system
and all of other other institutions from
this corruption
is to take the power away from organized
crime and legally regulate the drug
markets
and until we do this corruption's only
going in one direction
you know people watch line of gt
okay some of the dramatic lines in it
are a bit far-fetched
but the substance of the corruption
is very well informed
what about the wire
have you seen the wire
i have the wire is a masterpiece and one
of the reasons it's a masterpiece is
because it's entirely based on
truth
i'm
my organization the law enforcement
action partnership i'm on the board of
the organization in america
and one of the other board members a guy
called neil franklin
he used to be on the murder squad in
baltimore
that's featured and he knows all of the
characters it's based on
based on all real people
um you know the guy who's just died
recently played the omar little that's
it oh my says that he knows that
little he says he knows the person
that's based on that's absolutely
accurate he's met him he knows him yeah
it's all accurate it says the only thing
that was really truly fictional was the
episode hamsterdam yeah yeah but the
rest of it there's real people and real
events
and it's a clear message the wire isn't
it you know this ain't no war wars end
yeah
yeah it's it you're right it's a
masterpiece uh we've got a few literally
a few minutes left and it feels like
it's flown by it's been really great to
chat uh can we do just a couple of like
human interest questions like you talked
about particularly the last big
realization that you had when you spent
seven months undercover and you felt
like you might get killed every day like
what was going on when you're there in
that situation why did you constantly
feel
at risk and all of that
well
i mean the burger bar boys had really
refined the
the intimidation they'd really got it
down to an art form
and this is this is what our drug policy
does you know the most successful gangs
get really good at this and they were
they were incredible the violence and
threats of violence that they'd used
towards me or they'd strip me at
gunpoint
uh once they took me to the edge of this
the race course what was your
relationship with them like how how how
did you ingratiate yourself with them
i built myself a bit of a reputation as
being a good thief um and i built a
reputation i've traded with a lot of the
people who who handle stolen goods
you know and i could give them gifts
sometimes and i was buying increasing
weights from them
um
and i just i just
i just became one of the people they
were happy to deal with directly okay
but there was i was never i was never
friendly with him right so so you go to
a meeting and suddenly they strip you at
gunpoint to make sure you haven't got a
wire on you or something is that right
yeah and that was that was an interest
that was a decision i was pleased to
make because the day before i'd got a
bit uncomfortable with how they were
behaving towards me and so the day after
i decided not to wear a wire and i've
been wearing a camera by that point but
that morning i thought will i shall i
show on titan i decided not to mate what
a good decision that was because when
they got me when they got me to the edge
of that park and they said right strip
you're [ __ ] five oh man you're
[ __ ] heat and one of them lifted up a
t-shirt and there was a gun tucked into
his tracksuit bottoms and now it's weird
the thoughts that go through your head
when you've got this adrenaline flood in
your head because i looked at that gun
in his track suit bottoms and i thought
how the hell is that elastic keeping
that gun
stranger thing and also when he says
you're [ __ ] five oh man and i
remember looking at him thinking you're
not old enough to have seen a wi-fi
though yeah again another just weird
things go through your head yeah yeah
and
how do you keep your cool how do you
keep your cool under that kind of
pressure because the wheel throws
pressure in our jobs
yeah maybe not like that mate imagine
you would wake up in the morning i'm
just here with a with a gun and my
elastic going you're 5-0
demanding you strip
i mean i can imagine that part anyway
but
how do you deal with that how do you
deal with with that level of pressure
because we talk about stressful jobs but
that is something else entirely
well that's an interesting question
because you know as a young man when i
when i've had my first near-death
experiences working undercover i was i
was really pleased with myself because
you know you don't know how you're going
to deal with [ __ ] like that do you you
don't know
but i had the advantage like some people
do apparently i had the advantage that
when i ever said what that doesn't work
now god no but as a young man if what
when i had a surge of adrenaline i had
the sensation that time was slowing down
and i had a calming feeling that i could
i could think very clearly and that i
had all the time in the world to think
so i could do it with complete
confidence
and i just had this feeling right okay
this problem got to think it through
deal with it and i just stayed in that
sort of moment that fueled by adrenaline
so to speak
and you know it boosted my ego because
i'm coming away from this and my
colleagues my peers are saying wow you
know you're not breaking a sweater what
look at you and that boosted my ego as a
young man suited me thinking wow you
know i'm finally good at something
but no one told me that that was
destroying the fabric of my brain
um that these events you know
these
high high
intense experiences were causing me
damage you know i'm i'm diagnosed now
with chronic ptsd
and i i have
most most days now are good
but i have some dark days
and
i i i jumped and i you know i jumped
into all of those times with wild
abundant and carelessness really i had
no idea that would do that to me and no
one told me
you know the gung-ho culture within
policing within drugs policing
no one no one told me that that perhaps
i need to take a breath and and look
after myself
the only way i looked after myself as
was with alcohol
did you find yourself almost becoming
addicted to that kind of high octane
lifestyle
though and yeah in the first few years
um
it drove me and i and i loved it i did i
loved
the intellectual exercise of
the lying people lying to people the
manipulating people and i also love the
challenge of
you know it's it's like a rapid
improvement it's a rapid
learning exercise and we all like to
feel like we learned something we've
developed personally don't we but it's
like that's turning it up to 100. it's
like you learn so much about yourself
literally in minutes
and that's a very heady experience
to be able to learn and and how you
acutely learn people's body language and
you become so quickly responsive to it
yeah it's very heady but
by the time i was working with the
burger bar boys it was just exhausting i
was i think i was already probably
multiply traumatized well i will have
been
and i was just piling on top by then
and neil you know again going back to
carl hart's point of
the word we see the word junkie or we
hear the word junky we get an image we
get we do that exact same thing with the
word gangster
but you've been with these people you
you've talked with them you've spoken
them you've seen the probably the other
side to them
who are these people are do they have
similar personality traits or is it
literally from every part of you know
the spectrum that life has to offer
yeah i get in discussion with some drug
policy
people i know about my use of the word
gangsters
and i do use the word consciously and i
know that it has it conjures up mixed
images for different people but it's a
hook for an audience so i use it
but
i say gangsters and some of them are
generally vicious but they're all a
product of the system they're all a
product of drug drug prohibition and
they would not be the way they are
unless drug prohibition
but
if it wasn't there they wouldn't
and we need to be aware of that now i'll
give you an example there was a
back in
2001 i met
this kid who was a part of a gang and he
was 16 when i met him
and he was a friendly kid you know i
could have a laugh with him he was a
nice kid good sense of humor
and then six months later he'd become a
terrifying 17 year old
and i'd seen him change in that period
of time and he was changing and he was
learning to become casually violent and
casually and to intimidate people
and whereas at the start
i'd have a laugh with him by the end he
casually bashed my head into a lamp post
just to let me know his boss bang the
ego as we're walking past
and i i saw that change and it was a
conscious effort for him to learn to be
like that
because that's how his peers taught him
he had to survive and he's right because
if you're casually violent like that you
don't get grassed up if people are
scared of you you don't get grassed up
people are scared of you people don't
provide a witness statement you survive
longer
now i don't i'm sure
now oh bear in mind that that quite then
back to back in 2001 it was unusual for
someone so young to be at the front line
of heroin and crack cocaine dealing now
it's more often than not they are now
they're all there's 50 000 of them now
more
changed brought by drug prohibition you
know well done
um
but i'm sure that that kid when he was
12 or 13 wasn't looking to a future
thinking i'm going to be learning how to
be as violent as possible to be part of
a drug dealing ganga don't believe it
this is what
the current system did to him
now the berger bar boys they were second
and third generation gangsters
they've been brought up that way by
their parents
but their parents didn't have to have
been that way
we're doing this
to our communities we're doing this to
our young men it's changing the
personalities of our young men
and it plays out you see it play out
with the growing knife violence for the
younger ones the next generation
they've got older peers
telling them you've got a you need a
reputation
because their communities have been
changed by this law
and how bad are the next generation
going to be unless we turn it around
well neil on that happy note
we've come to the end of our listen it's
been great and i know you've got stories
for days so perhaps if you're kind
enough to come back at some point we can
delve into a little bit more uh but for
now uh we're gonna ask you a couple of
questions from our local supporters that
only they will get to see but before we
do that we'll wrap up the main interview
here by asking you the question we
always ask at the end which is what is
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that you think we really
should be
okay now explain the mechanism of
corruption that brings us halfway
halfway to this next point
that corruption
means that cop 26 the great
environmental uh meeting which was
trying to turn around the client trying
to stop the climate catastrophe
many countries which are the most
important countries which need to stop
deforestation
make pledges
but they can't go carry through those
pledges
because they don't control their own
backyards
drug dealing transnational crime does
so i mentioned west africa guinea-bissau
guinea
uh
senegal senegal sierra leone but if you
but if you look at latin america as well
all of the equatorial countries
governance has dissolved
the governments have no say of what goes
on in the forests it cannot be stopped
because drugs organized crime is too
powerful there is only two options
to stop this disaster
and that is to get transnational
organized crime around the table
i'm sure that'll be popular
we want the if we want to stop the
planet burning that's option one
or we take their power away from them by
taking their market off them by legally
regulating those are the two choices if
we want to stop the lungs of the world
being cut down
neil it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on if
people want to find you online or your
work where do they go
well please follow the law enforcement
action partnership uh leap uk we have
the website on twitter and instagram we
are at uk leap
my twitter is
at woodsy zero
which is
i know i chose it before i knew i was
going to be public
but you'll find you'll find me and the
book the books uh if you want more
undercover stories it's good cop bad war
if you want a history of british drug
policy it's drug wars fantastic stuff
neil woods thank you so much and thank
you for watching and listening we're
gonna do our locals questions now but
thank you so much for the moment we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
which go out at 7 pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
the government has just passed
a bill which is
[Music]
holy [ __ ] i know
[Music]